hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about my second Kumi Joe
so my second paired form for the Joe um
it is like a brother sister with the
first one so to me those kind of
intermix in lots of interesting ways and
so they're really cool to learn one
right after the other um stop talking
about it and get Josh out here we're
going to do it Josh let's go to
work all right let's talk about the
second form as I teach it this is very
similar to the ninth form of cyto iwama
system if you're following along in that
um a few things are changed um and it's
a little bit different but basically the
same idea okay in this just like the
first form let's go ahead and switch
directions actually here okay just like
the first form which is scy the's eth
form we're both in ski but in this form
we're in range so the first form we're
out of range this form we're in range
and the she the person who's going to
win the form is open now when Josh comes
into ski all I'm going to do is step
back and I'm going to use this uh uh
Masashi barai so that circular actions
of mhi bar and then bang I'm right back
on line so I knocked him off and we're
online so actually we just switched
positions here right so Josh is now in
the opposite side of what I was so if
we're looking at this as a form which it
is we can start to realize that these
are two different ideas from the same
position so in one form we're learning
two ideas from the same position okay
now what Josh could do here is go into
jodan guch and he can do it in such a
way that when he hits me I can't return
shot on him right so that's one of the
things that I think is highlighted in
all of these Kum Joe is that uh we can
transition our our ski Kamai into a kin
Kamai or a kin Kamai into ski Kamai Etc
as we go right so what's basically
happening in this is we're at range Josh
comes in I try to make distance and Josh
immediately turns that in over and he
goes into this okay now what's nice
about that jodon gu huge is it could be
if I was receding or if I'm pushing
right so meaning if I receded really far
okay Josh can cover that distance and
hit me with the jodan guch right whereas
if Josh threw another ski and I receded
really far he'll miss me right so that
jodan guch allows him to account for
distance also if I were to push into
Josh after this so I go here and I push
in Josh can pull himself back and still
hit me so that's a really important
aspect of this going into the kin my
situation is that he's longer than I am
and so he can use that to his Advantage
whether I'm pushing at him or receding
away from him okay now in that situation
I have to somehow cover the distance of
him doing that right so meaning when I
do this I have to cover this distance
somehow so what I'm going to do is a
really clever way I'm going to come uh
Uchi a which is a rising strike I'm
going to come right up underneath and
clip him right under the chin here is
what I'm looking for now this is great
because from this situation I've already
gone into an essent ban noai right so
meaning if Josh was real quick and he
kept striking I could still defend
myself against whatever he shoots but if
I'm in time with him I can come right up
underneath and hit him now if he comes
in to hit me after this it doesn't
matter because I'm in Boni no Kamai
right so once I get into this position I
can universally block basically anything
he throws from a ski to any kind of
overhead strike low strikes doesn't
matter I can block it from this position
so by coming and clipping him in this
way I've got a real advantage in
defending myself after that right okay
so we're here I hop back I cover the
distance whatever it is and I come up
and I get him here okay now from this
position he's probably going to try to
come around and hit me low so that's
what he's looking for and of course I
could just defend it bang but now I
haven't gotten any kind of Advantage so
instead of that what I'm going to do is
slide from here to in between his elbows
and as Josh comes for me I'm just going
to step with him and he gets all bound
up and he's in a bad way right and that
gives me lots of opportunity to continue
to go with him right actually let's go
ahead and shoot it from the the other
side this time all right so I'm here
like this Josh comes in after me I step
back to fend as he raises up I come
underneath and I clip I shoot through
his arms and as he comes in I get this
really nice position here coming off to
the side so this is teaching me a way at
close range to bind up Josh's arms as we
look at the series of my progression
here we're going to see lots of ways to
deal with binding up their arms which is
going to be useful in close quarter
situations which is what we might find
ourselves in if we were using skii
versus kenami I.E kenami is a better
Kamai for equalized weapons because it's
going to give him maximum reach and
power but if I get caught in a
close-range situation I might have to go
to ski Kamai and so if I do that how can
I bind up this guy's arms to keep him
from from getting me so we're going to
see a lot of those here in this
beginning so one more time this form is
we in distance here Josh comes in I try
to hop out Josh extends I come up
underneath I shoot through his arms and
as he goes to get me all I do is Step
beside him and throw him that can be a
really difficult part I will teach that
uh throw or control in a separate video
because I could really talk for about 15
more minutes about it so we'll put that
in a separate video for you guys but
that's the rough idea of my second Kumi
Joo I'm Christopher Hines Joshua thi my
Sal mcdels behind that camera right
there and we'll see you she she gave one
of these we'll see you guys in a future
video